I love this follow-up to this yeah me  too a Texas community continues to rally  around a man whose wife was killed in  the O Paso mass shooting Antonio Bosco  lost his wife of 22 years yesterday we  told you how thousands of strangers came  to his wife's funeral over the weekend  after he said there was almost no family  that he had know Paso to attend hours  after the funeral mr. bass goes SUV was  stolen and it was wrecked well guess  what happened yesterday a local Ford  dealership stepped in to help take a  look Casa Ford presented mr. Basco with  keys to a new SUV they even gave him a  pressure washer because what happened  was the pressure washer that he used to  actually wash cars which is his business  that too was stolen so he got a new one  from an anonymous donor who bought it  for it makes you want to go to Casa Ford  buy a car that's very nice thank you  David beg no good folks in El Paso